voilà un smartphone qui est super cool
c'est le samsung galaxy z fleet 3 est ce
qu'il est intéressant est ce qu'il faut
se positionner on va tous regardé les
bénéfices d'avoir un plus grand écran
extérieur le bénéfice de l'écran
intérieure ont regardé la pliure on va
regarder si la batterie 3300 millions
terreur elle tient le choc ou pas on va
regarder si la performance est là on va
regarder les usages on va voir un petit
peu les limites qu'est ce qui fonctionne
qu est-ce qui fonctionne pas forcément
des choses qui fonctionnent pas mais
surtout où tout est hyper calme si c'est
le prix quand même je ne prends jamais
les tarifs par tirage devrait être en
détail par ailleurs je me sais c'est le
fric il élargit les non-initiés n'est
pas là il est là
1059 euros ça va être extrêmement
agressif ça reste cher très cher mais ça
ramène quand même le smartphone plus bas
on va donc tous dire tout savoir et vous
allez voir ça c'est vraiment intéressant
[Musique]
écran à l'avant plus grands
certification ipx8 résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière plus de performances
enfin ce smartphone est en tout cas sur
la fiche technique plus intéressant que
ce qu'on trouvait sur le z flip 1 il n'y
a pas une numéro deux dans les passes et
directement numéro 3 le premier truc moi
qui m'intéresse vraiment mais vraiment
vraiment vraiment cet écran extérieur
avant on avait un écran de 1,1 pousse
ici on a un écran de 1,9 pouces un écran
qui vous permet de faire plein plein
plein de choses et notamment avec un
petit double tape là ici devenir active
et la caméra et ça c'est cool sacre en
extérieur il est super intéressant et
pour plusieurs raisons souvenez-vous le
modèle d'avant 9 un écran qui étaient
plus petits la en un écran qui est
vachement plus grand et ça me plaît
double tap et vous venez l'activé alors
jack premiers trucs à savoir c'est la
luminosité moi c'est une erreur j'ai
fait lorsque je les prie dans la rue je
voyais absolument il faut savoir qu'à
houston on est en plein été balancés
comme ça et là pour venir régler votre
luminosité soit plus lumineux soit moins
lumineux c'est pareil pour le son vous
venez désactivé vous mettez en vibreur
vous coupez le son vous réactivez le
sont pas c'est extrêmement pratique en
vous avez ici à votre musique tous les
morceaux vous voulez venir écouter donc
ça c'est vachement bien très facile vous
appuyez sur lecture up morceau vous
arrêter vous soyez vous avez la météo
vous venez tourner ici vous avez votre
petit programme de la journée vous
retrouver ici vos a enfin bref il ya
beaucoup de widgets vous n'êtes pas
obligé tous les maîtres nager tous nus
pour vous faire la démo mais voulait
s'est appuyé dessus ça vous permet de
venir les supprimer les weeds devenir
elle est réorganisée d'ailleurs si vous
voulez lire et organisé vous avez
également un truc qui va choix
intéressant qui se situe à l'intérieur
pour le coup vous allez ici dans vos
paramètres dans écran externe jc waneux
aia basé sur l'android on sait ce qui va
choix intéressant c'est qu'il a été un
petit peu retravaillé forcément sera
smartphone qui se plie pas vous avez le
style d'horloge on va le regarder dans
quelques instants et vous avez surtout
de widgets que vous allez pouvoir venir
ici modifier supprimer
activer/désactiver donc là c'est
vachement coup même les réorganiser vous
avez également l'horloge alors ça c'est
un truc qui écoule polir modifié bien
évidemment votre horloge choisir il ya
plein de motifs différents mais de la
couleur mettre un petit singe un petit
chien ce que vous voulez en moi j'ai mis
celle là parce que pour moi j'ai les
infos essentielles la date l'heure et le
niveau de batterie bon après voyez il y
en a pour tout le monde et pour tous les
goûts pour me venir changer les couleurs
en bas ici si vous voulez une couleur
pouvez même mettre une petite image
d'arrière plan si vous le souhaitez
voyez donc on peut qu'aller vachement
loin au niveau de cet écran extérieur
donc là dessus je trouve que samsung est
bien bossé il ya vraiment une superbe
idée puis à vous avez les notifications
sur le côté il ya une autre affiche ne
connaîtra sur cet écran là c'est que
lorsque vous aider à prendre une photo
vous appuyez sur le capteur d'empreintes
digitales son côté fait un double tap ça
vous activez votre caméra ultra grand
angle là pour passer sur le grand angle
et ensuite vous passez sur le côté vous
arrivez sur la vidéo donc choisissez
entre photos et vidéos si vous voulez
faire une photo vous appuyez sur le
bouton de volume hop là regardez ça fait
une photo mais si vous voulez un petit
retardateur patins double cliquer là
vous l'avez ah voilà la photo ce fait
donc là c'est vraiment très très
pratique donc à plusieurs façons de
devenir faire ça petit regret peut-être
j'aurais aimé pouvoir venir vous mais
voyait qu'un petit pinch to zoom ce
n'est pas possible je peux pas cet écran
extérieur vous permet également de voir
bien évidemment vos sms je vais répondre
à un appel directement ici par contre
lorsque vous répondez vous parlais que
les haut parleurs forcément vous n'avez
rien à vous mettre sur l'oreille sauf si
vous avez des petits galaxy 2 2 ap rsa
peut être relativement cool sinon tout
le monde va entendre vos conversations
un autre petit truc intéressant lorsque
vous faites une photo comme ça eh bien
vous ouvrez
tac vous avez accès à votre appareil
photo mais comme vous avez pas
déverrouiller en réalité pas 14
d'empreintes digitales et puis pas le
code ou schémas et compagnie et bien
vous n'avez pas que ça vos photos c'est
complètement bloquée bloqués sauf les
photos vous allez faire maintenant vous
verrez les dernières photos que vous
avez fait ne vous verrez pas les photos
qui ont été verrouillés il faut venir
déverrouiller votre smartphone avec
votre doigt et là vous avez accès à vos
autres photos donc ça je trouve ça quand
même vachement rassurant et ça c'est
vachement cool en termes de
confidentialité et un autre petit détail
qui est aussi super bien vous l'avez
peut-être vu lire avec la version qu'on
avait avec le z flippin vous avez ici à
cette petite partie vous appuyez dessus
ça vous active le moniteur externe alors
vous à l'intérieur vous voyez ce que
vous allez lire shooter et la personne
en face elle se voit et comme on a un
écran qui est quand même suffisamment
grand ici il ya un vrai bénéfice ça vous
aura pas échappé ici on est sur un
smartphone qui explique ça veut donc
dire qu'à l'intérieur on a un smartphone
qui se plie avec une petit plaisir une
petite piqûre qu'on se sent sous le
doigt juste là à la différence dans
cette folle de troie qui va être plié
comme ça et plus grands comme les
épaules de deux et comme la z fold est
bien ici lorsque vous venez scrollé vous
sentez vraiment vous sentez réellement
ça peut être embêtant lorsque vous avez
un scroll infinie par exemple sur vos
différents réseaux sociaux sur instagram
on peut se dire que c'est un petit peu
relou d'avoir ça voyez tout le temps
sous le doigt alors c'est vrai peut-être
que ça peut vous gêner moi je le sens il
ya un moment ça me gonfle un peu alors
je viens de mettre en bas et j'ai plus
tout ce ce problématique là c'est juste
une question de positionnement on trouve
assez facilement sa position mais c'est
vrai qu'au début voyons un sens dira
j'ai tout le temps sous le doivent voilà
bon par contre ce qui est super c'est
que là vous le voyez c'est qu'on a un
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
sans mayer s'associent nouveauté avec ce
modèle là donc ça apporte beaucoup plus
de fluidité lorsque vous venez escrocs
les le fait d'avoir ce format long avec
un ratio de 22 9e s'est super bien parce
qu'on va vraiment bien sur toute la
longueur et notamment pour l'instant g
et massa je me sens super bien par
contre il ya un côté un peu négatif est
bien c'est que lorsque vous avez vous
regardé des films des séries vous allez
voir vous allez voir des bandes noires
assez grande sur le côté par exemple sur
youtube voyez j'ai une grande bande sur
le côté et si je veux venir sonner et
bien je vous l'accordé mans j'ai
vachement de contenus dans mon image
donc ça c'est quand même un peu
problématique et sait pas où trouver et
voyez quand vous regardez un film ces
bandes s'est pas complètement gg une
fois de plus vous perdez vachement de
contenu en venant vous met dedans comme
ça un écran qui se plie on peut venir le
poser comme ça et si vous venez de poser
à vous le voyez peut-être tout de suite
vous allez avoir ici l'écran du dessus
quand vous le voyez vous ce prix du haut
il va venir être un petit peu plus
bleuté et en bas ça va être blanc moi
celle inverse face à moi chez si je suis
plus blanc ici fut bleuté donc bien
l'utiliser en étant plié comme ça pour
venir naviguer et bien c'est pas
réellement le bon plan le solde provient
qui est vraiment adapté c'est la partie
photo vous venez leur plié la partie la
remonte mais ça vous fait comme un
espèce de système un petit peu pour rire
pour venir faire des photos ça par
contre ça vraiment extrêmement pratique
j'ai avec le vrai bénéfice se situe là
pour venir l'utiliser lorsqu'il est plié
c'est vraiment pour la partie photo est
aujourd'hui en tout cas uniquement pour
la partie photo et si notamment voulait
venir vous positionnez ici me faire un
p'tit time lapse c'est hyper simple très
pratique vous posez là vous enregistrez
et ça c'est cool il ya toute une partie
également partage d'écran si vous
souhaitez effectivement utiliser la
partie du haut pour regarder un film une
série est la partie du bas pour vos
emails vous pouvez le faire
personnellement j'en ai pas du tout les
usages je suis pas sûr que ce smartphone
là soit vraiment destinés à cet usage la
plus le z feu le 3 mai sandor parade et
si quelques jours dont vous invite dès
maintenant à bien vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait mais c'est également
un smartphone taillé pour la performance
et si on nous met quasiment ce qui est
mieux on nomme un processeur de qualcomm
c'est le stand dragonne 888 qui était
présenté au mois de décembre l'année
dernière il ya le sud 188 plus mais là
ce n'est pas le cas on se pose pas la
question de ceux de 888 plus on se pose
la question que du bus à 88 et surtout
on se pose pas la question des
processeur samsung et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant on parle pas ici des casinos
ce nom qualcomm c'est un dragon 888 tout
s'accouplaient à 8 giga drame c'est un
truc qui est assez intéressant c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui est dédié
pour le gaming vous avez ce qu'il faut
vous avez de la fluidité sa réponse ça
marche bien aucun problème là dessus il
ya juste un truc que j'ai remarquée et
que je viens reproche à ce smartphone
mais pas forcément lors du gaming c'est
que la partie supérieure ici elle
chauffe vous posez votre main c'est très
chaud car c'est très chaud c'est chaud
ça me brûle pas la main mais c'est chaud
c'est ce que celle là il ya température
ambiante c'est complètement normal ici
par contre c'est chaud vous mettez un
film ça devient chose et pas besoin de
jouer beaucoup c'est vraiment le côté un
petit peu un petit peu dommage un peu
négatif alors si vous mettez une coque
de protection et bien la chaleur va
venir être absorbées vous le sentirez
pas mais si vous l'utilisez comme ça
directement il peut y avoir un petit
côté un peu un confort temps à regarder
un film mal tenir comme ça et à sentir
la chaleur arrive pas ce que je vous dis
là il est chaud et pour autant j'ai pas
fait une grande session gaming
d'ailleurs pas joué du tout alors
assurez-vous 1 malgré tout ça reste
raisonnable on va pas bien se brûler les
doigts ici bonne foi qui est super
intéressant c'est la question de
l'autonomie on a ici une batterie 3300
milliampères heure là où il ya beaucoup
de constructeurs qui vont sur des
batteries 4000 5,5 millions paiera même
des fois 6000 milan perd heures mais
c'est assez rare et plus surtout dans
l'entrée milieu de gamme l'aï si samsung
a fait choix de nous mettre une batterie
de trois mille trois cent millions
terreur alors il ya forcément une
question de facteur est une question de
taille a toujours ses questions qui
viennent se poser lorsqu'on vient
fabriquer un produit comme celui-là mais
pour autant est-ce qu'une batterie de
3300 billets en terreur ça fait tâche la
batterie j'ai réussi à les tenir une
journée et demi à deux jours ça dépendra
une fois de plus de vos usages si vous
l'utilisez en ont beaucoup joué si vous
êtes tout le temps sur vos réseaux
sociaux arrivera un moment où ça ne fera
pas trop mais là une journée et demie à
deux jours sans absolument aucun
problème le truc un peu négatif par
contre que je vais avoir ici que ce
smartphone est bien c'est comme les
smartphones qu'on va retrouver
actuellement vous n'avez plus de blogs
de charge intégrée si vous voulez un
bloc de charge rapide il faut bien
l'acheter en plus sinon moi je les
branches est ici avec un bloc de charge
pas très rapide j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps à venir le chargeur il ya un côté
un petit peu frustrant donc lorsque vous
venez d'acheter je sais ça fait un petit
peu d'argent venir ajouter un bloc de
charge rapide directement sur le sort de
samsung ou chez les revendeurs pour ne
pas avoir à galérer et avoir une
recharge qui est un peu lente et
fastidieuse tâche le smartphone que
j'aime beaucoup moi c'est c'est ce
format qui est très différent c'est
vraiment cool d'avoir truqué extrêmement
compact ça passe très très facilement
dans la peau de regarder je le prends je
glisse dans la poche c'est très très
très discret bon mise à part ici j'ai un
masque donc forcément ça laisse un peu
le truc mais sinon regardez là ici il
n'ya pas de masque je glisse c'est
vraiment extrêmement discret donc
j'adore j'adore le format vraiment il ya
un seul toit que je me reprocher si je
trouve un petit peu glissant vous l'avez
au niveau des façades lassalien
légèrement glissé lors lorsque je lourd
bien je prends à demain parce que j'ai
peur en réalité de le faire tomber j'ai
peur de le casser alors ce qui est quand
même rassurant aussi c'est que vous avez
un corning gorilla glass l'ictus je vous
passe un petit peu le truc technique
mais c'est je dirais la meilleure
protection on va avoir ici au niveau du
verre donc ça c'est plutôt cool est
plutôt rassurant néanmoins lorsqu'il
tombe vous restez toujours si vous
tombez sur un petit recoin un caillou
quoi que ce soit de venir l'endommager
ou en tout cas venir le reggae ce que je
vous conseille et d'ailleurs sanction
que le propose sur son site c'est
intéressant on est loin de la rose a mis
un lien en bas dans la description est
bien c'est que d'avoir des petites
protection vous avez des coqs qui sont
très très cool une partie là une partie
la relier au centre par un petit
élastique tout ça vraiment mince et très
jolie en plus le truc qui coule aussi
ces conditions on a une structure en
aluminium qui ont plus de ça vient
rajouter à la légèreté on a un
smartphone qui fait 183 g il n'est pas
hyper lourd alors il part un petit peu
lorsque vous prenez dans la main comme
ça si vous prenez par exemple un iphone
ici bon on les croyait un peu plus lourd
a certainement mais comme là sur une une
taille qui est un peu réduite on les
sent un peu plus si vous l'ouvrez comme
ça vous sentirez un peu moins les 183 g
parce que vous aurez une meilleure
répartition soit votre main donc c'est
quand même assez léger je trouve ça
vraiment sympa toute la partie
logicielle je dis moi j'aime bien c'est
wang haiwen us déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo je vous invite à venir
la découvrir et c'est comme je vous le
disais vous avez des fonctionnalités qui
sont rajoutés pour le smartphone vient
supplier toute la partie écran externe
que vous n'avez pas forcément sur des
smartphones qui ne se plient pas c'est
logique à côté de ça il ya quand même
des petites qui sont pas encore
complètement optimisé et notamment voyez
je vous présente sur facebook si je
viens rajouter une photo ici mais par
exemple mon pote léo et je veux venir le
tag est directement je clique pour venir
le tagger et là j'ai vu sur sa tête et
il disparaît complètement alors là je
venir taper le nom les eaux je ne vois
rien je suis vraiment l'aveuglent venir
cacher l'écran pour que ça me le propose
et là par contre je peux venir appuyer
c'est lui il est agréé donc ça voyez
c'est des petits points de détails mais
ça a son importance alors j'imagine que
peut-être facebook à venir corriger ça
c'est simple son buffet facebook est un
problème c'est pas rencontrer partout
mais makatu voyez encore quelques
petites applications un petit peu
réfractaires récalcitrants qui peuvent
possiblement poser problème toute la
partie photo elle est vraiment
intéressant vous avez si un double
module 12 mégapixels ultra grand angle
et votre grand temps et intérieur vous
avez un 10 mégapixels bon alors on
connaît le savoir-faire de samsung au
niveau des photos par contre un truc qui
est vraiment intéressant ici typiquement
grâce au form factor pour moi la caméra
de celle fille à l'intérieur ne sert
strictement à rien et a plus rien du
tout vous n'avez plus besoin parce que
vous allez avoir des photos qui seront
pas de mauvaise qualité elles sont quand
même plutôt pas mal mais si vous voulez
vraiment de belles photos en selle fille
vous mettez la double tap up alors bien
évidemment vous verrez pas avec le très
très bon format mais vous comprenez
faites votre photo regardez le résultat
est là ça fonctionne toujours un bien
meilleur rendu ici avec ma caméra de
selphy extérieur qu avec ma caméra de
cette fille intérieur en termes de piqué
en termes de couleurs en termes de
luminosité ma caméra extérieure grand
temps de 12 mégapixels ça n'a
strictement rien à voir il ya donc en
réalité vous avez deux caméras qui sont
vraiment intéressantes vous avez votre
grand-angle vous et votre
ultra-grand-angle grand-angle marche
vraiment bien grosse grosse maîtrise de
sa mission que ça marche très très bien
et puis l' ultra grand-angle vous
servira vraiment lorsque vous avez un
bâtiment attention à pas d'y ajouter
tout et n'importe quoi pour ne pas avoir
une qualité qui se dégrade mais c'est
vrai quand même que dans l'ensemble ça
marche très très bien on peut venir nous
mais si on le souhaite mais globalement
il n'ya vraiment pas d'intérêt on peut
monter jusqu'à un zoom x 10,9 vraiment
je ne vous recommande pas vous restez
sur votre foi le foie de éventuellement
si vous voulez vous n'allez pas au delà
de ça il est hyper compact il est hyper
innovant il est moderne on peut se la
péter on est dans la rue je loupe comme
ça je leur accroche comme ça c'est
vraiment un produit qui laisse pas du
tout du tout du tout indifférent je
trouve super beau super élégant on a
vraiment l usage avec l'écran avant
qu'on n'avait pas écran extérieur plutôt
qu'on a des pas avec le modèle d'avant
on peut voir ces messages on peut faire
des photos on a vraiment beaucoup plus
d'usagers alors c'est pas non plus
l'écran qu'on va utiliser le plus mais
malgré tout il est là il sert vraiment à
quelque chose de retracer très très cool
le format est malin moi j'aime beaucoup
et surtout ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
le prix 1000 59 euros ça leur approche
du marché se rapproche même du haut du
panier du marché mais malgré tout ils
sont dans la course et dirait que ça
rapproche quand même vraiment les
smartphones qui se plie du grand public
donc il ya un très gros pas en avant
j'imagine que samsung continuera comme
ça dans les temps à venir à se
rapprocher davantage mais j'aime
beaucoup ça vraiment vraiment vraiment
bien il ya un point par contre qui m'a
un peu posé problème c'est lorsque je le
prenais que j'en mettais un google maps
et je me baladais dans la ville pour
trouver mon chemin eh bien je trouvais
qu'elle impute il fonctionnait pas très
très bien avec le gps je le prends je le
mets à l'avant comme ça et normalement
si vous êtes dans maps brute sur votre
carte le sens dans lequel vous êtes
c'est le sens de la marche si vous
permet de vous repérer à 21h dans le bon
sens de là où je vais dans ce sens là il
pas dans l'autre sens et ben ça marchait
pas ça me mettait sur le côté stephen a
eu beaucoup de mal à me repérer je
comprenais pas je me suis planté un
paquet de fois gras mais ne comprends
pas je sais où je suis là je suis pas là
qu'est ce qui se passe une fois vous le
savez on y arrive mais c'est pas très
intuitif par rapport à ce que je
pourrais avoir avec un iphone ou c'est
très intuitif jeu mais comme ça sa main
et vous le retrouvez dans plein de
couleurs différentes alors je les ai pas
toutes apprises par coeur vous avez
crème noir vert lavande moi c'est le
crème que j'ai là d'ailleurs y'a pas
couleurs exclusives ça me semble pas un
comme d'ailleurs une fois de plus le
lien est en bas dans la description
aller jeter un oeil si vous ne voulez en
gris en blanc ou en rose ce sera
uniquement sur le magasin de samsung en
ligne samsung points comme une fois de
plus le lien et en maths dans la
description ramasser un smartphone qui
sont vraiment très très très bon c'est
pas celui qui fera le plus de choses en
photo par contre si vous voulez un
smartphone avec une top innovation un
tarif qui est vraiment hyper cool même
si sa recherche j'en conviens galaxy z
fig 3 c'est vraiment une petite tuerie
mais en tout cas j'ai beaucoup aimé
utiliser ce téléphone maintenant il est
l'heure passer au test du samsung galaxy
cette folle de 3 avec son hespel fold
edition on en reparle dans quelques
jours à bord de la nouvelle montre
connectés de samsung adresse à bientôt
ce sera la classique qu'on reste
ensemble et puis les meubles 2 nous tous
en noir parra parce qu'un écosystème qui
se développent des symptômes de plus en
plus avec de très jolies choses à dire a
vous de me dire vous maintenant oui vous
vous trahir caméra qu'est ce que vous en
pensez samsung galaxy ses deux filles 3
ça vous tente ça vous plaît c'est un
format qui pourrait vous intéresser est
ce que ça vous plaît puis elle est ce
que vous vous verriez qu'un smartphone
qui se plie comme ça et qui vient
vraiment gagner en compacité dans votre
poche marc et moi tout ça en bar en bas
là juste en bas en commentaire on se
retrouve très vite nous pour continuer à
par l'état qui est en train de préparer
la rentrée je tourne cette vidéo on est
au mois d'août 2009 il faut le savoir je
prépare la rentrée et croyez moi croyez
moi il va se passer des choses